one time when I was a kid in the crib my
mom walked in on my dad holding a toy
just out of reach and I was trying to
reach for it
and grab it out of the [ __ ] crib hmm
and my dad wouldn't let me grab it and
my mom said bill what the [ __ ] are you
doing and my dad said teach him about
life farted when a laughs couldn't held
it in dude it's so sexy to fart swear to
God sort of God swear to God one time
when I was in high school I [ __ ]
farted couldn't help it somebody no dude
I messed up this story and it's fine
because it makes it better it's gonna be
like the [ __ ] movie where you think
one things happening and then you
realize at the end of the movie that
this is really what was happening Wow
his name was Doug dude you know when you
do something like fart or trip or
something embarrassing and people see
and they notice and you get so hot
inside you're like hold on a second does
anybody want to cook some bacon on my
chest cuz now's the time right you
almost feel tingly they start losing
your vision cuz you big puss that
happens to me
well one time a kid named Doug farted
and he thought it was gonna be
I saw the way he was sitting he was
spray is trying to spread his cheeks you
know and make it go but instead of that
I guess his butt was tight cuz it went
and it was in mr. Thatcher's class and I
turned around and I saw him and he was
doing this and I saw him feel hot inside
and it was so subtle but I [ __ ]
ripped cuz it made me feel human I knew
that he was feeling hot inside just by
his face and I was like that's how that
looks
wiebe me
wee-bey mean and so uh let's cut that on
the thing by the way on the video so
this way we know people know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about the wee-bey mean
from from will the wire you know what we
don't what you do [ __ ] yeah dude
I've been get rid of Ivan stay in the
room one fire would never do that dude
uh and so uh so uh yeah what was I
talking about
oh yeah so Doug [ __ ] farted but what
he should have done honestly was said
yup
ladies um ladies I'm free tonight that's
what you should do when you fart you
should immediately go ladies I'm free
tonight and not as a joke and not an
irony mean it [ __ ] yeah dude nothing
sexier than being you nothing sexier
than being you dude if you're boring be
boring
that's so goddamn sexy and own it dude
don't think you're good with chicks if
you're not if you're not then don't be
good with chicks and own it and all of a
sudden you're sexy sort of God you gotta
be you dude there's so many people out
there doing dumb [ __ ] like getting
[ __ ] really wide pants or like or
like getting like you know circular
glasses like these chicks with the
circular glasses or that everyone thinks
they're bad rabbit or would have [ __ ]
that guy's name bad bunny
everyone thinks they're bad bunny taking
pictures like this keep your tongue any
[ __ ] mouth you're the same dude like
III really mean I'm a mean girl dude and
this is coming from a guy who [ __ ]
does that [ __ ] too so you know it's real
you know it's real
fartin say ladies drinks on me fart and
then say I guess I'm [ __ ] tonight what
the [ __ ]
bad bunny put a third eye is that pays
that a real thing that's not Photoshop
it's Photoshop he went out like that
with a third eye above his eye uh I mean
it doesn't even look good you know
hey dude you're [ __ ] so rich get a guy
to do it better get the guy from the
island to do it that movie with Ewan
McGregor and Scarlett Johansson oh this
looks like [ __ ] chocolate looks like
a cake um dude bad bunny always makes
the faces in between the photos bad
bunny is always making a face of a face
on the way to making a face he this is a
photo of bad bunny he'll be like this or
like hey man you're on your way keep
going and then take the photo